[Music]
[Laughter]
are you women
that wasn't even a near-miss Johnny come
sit down
you know kids do kind of scary that
mist or I would like to have you know
master Johnny Walsh and son I'd like to
present miss Linda for our public health
nurse well how do you do Johnny I'm very
happy to know pleased to meet you ma'am
you're new around here right yeah yeah
they moved into the county about oh
about a week ago
these folks took over the big old stalee
place but they've got a big family
haven't you Johnny sister till you're
older and right yeah yeah you've got two
sisters and they're expecting a new baby
for Christmas
oh how nice you know I'd like to meet
your mother and your father and your
sisters too new baby by cretan well you
don't have long to wait
do you not nearly as long as your folks
have been waiting for you to bring the
groceries home for supper
[Music]
help you going my way Johnny well I
think you might have a good idea to get
your car off the road Julie all right
serious okay all right bye bye later bye
bye Johnny
it was as simple as that a little boy
playing by the road and a public health
nurse making her daily rounds but that
is how the local health department first
met the wars family they just moved in
and were still working hard to get their
home in order they weren't quite ready
to welcome visitors
[Music]
miss Linda Thorpe was a qualified public
health nurse and an important part of
her job was to know how to make an
unexpected call like this seem as
natural as possible
yes it always takes a few minutes to get
over that first awkward feeling that
feeling of being ill at ease and
self-conscious Linda also knew that
smiling children could open doors of
friendship to their parents
and when an eager invitation to see the
new kittens was offered Linda felt sure
that these people would soon be her
friends
[Music]
although hardly a word had been spoken
linda knew that she had once again made
friends of strangers now she could
explain the work she was doing and why
the local health department maintains a
nursing service to help us all keep well
as part of her work Linda asked about
the baby that was expected in December
Mary Walsh hadn't been to see a doctor
yet
they'd been so busy fixing up the house
and she felt it could wait besides she
hadn't had any trouble with the other
children
but Linda explained that where there are
other children in the family you can
never afford to put off seeing a doctor
Mary was easily persuaded to visit the
doctor sooner than she had planned a few
days later she went to a local doctor
for a complete physical examination she
also had a chest x-ray something which
should be part of the routine
examination of every expectant mother in
most patients nothing unusual is found
but in Mary's case the doctor discovered
a small shadow on one of her lungs it
might mean very little but often it's
the only means of discovering early
tuberculosis because early TB has no
obvious symptoms it is often unsuspected
Berry was called back for further tests
for no diagnosis is complete until
specific laboratory tests are made every
technique of modern medicine is put to
work until the diagnosis is confirmed or
denied Mary Walsh didn't even feel sick
yet she had tuberculosis
now she became a responsibility of the
community and the community went to work
to help her get well
[Music]
maryanne I've done nothing but talk
about this since we first read these now
you know why it's best for you to go to
the hospital you know we can't afford a
big hospital bill it won't cause what
you think I know you mean well but we
can't accept charity no one's offering
you charity like the school's your
tuberculosis hospital is part of the
local government that you help support
it's job is to keep the community
healthy right by helping you the
community is also protecting itself but
we don't even have enough to pay someone
to come look after the children if I'm
not here we have no close relations near
here
Jim is a good man but he can't do
everything by himself miss Swain of our
Welfare Department is good at that sort
of thing she'll help you find a way you
make it all sound so simple but what
about the new baby your baby won't catch
tuberculosis from you if you do what the
doctor tells you but no case of TB is
simple you're more fortunate than some
because your case was caught early just
how long do you think it'll take in my
wife's case no one can say for sure but
mrs. Walsh should stay in the hospital
at least until after the baby is born
but that won't be for a month I won't do
it
I know this is a shock but when you
think of the children as well as
yourself I know you'll want to do the
sensible thing we both want to do what's
right
well hello James and Nancy to been
playing hard yeah oh and there's my pal
how are you Donny
haven't seen you for a long time
yes and I must protect the children
exactly
and the new baby most of all you need
rest and care now good food a place
where there are doctors and nurses the
right medicine you can only get that
kind of Kerala Hospital
leaving her family for the first time in
her life was made easier for Mary Walsh
by many helping hands
arrangements had been made for mrs.
Spencer to come and stay at home with
the children and take good care of them
while their mother was to be away miss
Swain of the welfare department had made
all the plans and preparations to keep
the family as happy as possible
Mary didn't know just where or how she'd
gotten tuberculosis but she knew she had
to go away to protect her children she
had to leave him for a while until she
was cured and as she looked at him she
wanted to do everything she could to
speed her own recovery and return to her
family well and happy
[Music]
the tuberculosis hospital wasn't far
from home and here Mary could had
complete rest in bed more than that
there was a skilled staff which with the
personal interest in it she knew that
she had the best medical attention in
the world and she didn't have to worry
about her family so she could keep her
mind at rest this is so important in
curing tuberculosis
[Music]
Linda made arrangements for the health
department to examine the rest of the
family right away to make sure that no
one else was sick this was one of the
many public health services in the
community which the local tuberculosis
Association had worked hard to establish
the children are treated with special
care for more than medical skill is
required to make it all seem to them
like a natural part of a big adventure
[Music]
Jim Walsh was also examined with the
latest x-ray equipment obtained with the
help of the local tuberculosis
Association when the tests showed that
none of the others had active TB the
family began to readjust itself with the
help of miss Swain of the welfare
department who offered friendly
suggestions on how to manage the house
while mother was away
the weeks passed Mary was busy and
content she knew that her family was
well taken care of especially the
children
Nellie's Spencer was wonderful with the
youngsters
and such peace of mind helped to speed
the progress of her recovery it was
comforting to know the farm was doing
nicely the things were good at home as
Mary grew stronger and healthier she
began to sit up and prepare for the day
when the baby was due Jim Walsh too was
counting the weeks and then the days
[Music]
congratulations it's a boy
mother doing fine
it was a healthy baby boy and he was at
home now with the rest of the children
growing fast to there he knew she was
getting better she'd soon be allowed on
her feet and then she'd be able to walk
around that was almost like being home
already they were making plans for her
return mrs. Benson the home
demonstration agent came in to show Jim
how to make it simple and easy for Mary
to do the housework when she came back
she should not be allowed to overwork it
was important to keep her from reaching
bending or stretching too much
yes everything was being done so that
Mary's work would be easier
everyone was learning to do his share
they're all getting ready to do their
own special jobs
[Music]
on his regular visits Jim saw Mary
steady progress and told her how the
baby was growing this was no ordinary
farewell there he was on her feet again
the day wasn't far off now and they
would all be walking together then one
day Linda Thorpe was able to tell Nellie
the good news very soon now Mary would
be coming home the final touches for the
homecoming were made mother was home
again
[Applause]
and now the public health nurse moves on
to help the many others who need her
care and attention she is a symbol of
the community's continuing effort to
keep its people well but she knows that
these are more than just her neighbors
these are her friends this is her
community and these are her people
[Applause]
[Music]